thanks for being with us here at noon
i'm heather mills a new sentencing
hearing for a drunk driver who crashed
and killed two people in 2018 henry
apparacio pleaded guilty in 2019 but the
state supreme court later threw out the
sentence over a technicality hector
mohan joins us now live outside the
courthouse in downtown to kind of
explain exactly what happened here
hector
well in the end henry apparicio ended up
getting the same sentence as the
original one which is 15 to 44 years in
prison he appeared virtually in court
today as the family had to relive the
whole process of another sentencing
hearing back in 2019 henrietta parisio
took a plea deal for the 2018 crash that
killed a couple dimaso and christa
puente they were in their car stopped at
a red light at hualapai in sahara when
they were rear ended by a parisian he
was traveling a hundred miles an hour
and driving four times the legal
drinking limit while parisia was
convicted two counts of dui resulting in
death and one reckless driving but then
later in 2021 the nevada supreme court
granted his petition for a new
sentencing the court kept the guilty
plea convinced conviction but threw out
the sentence the technicality if you're
wondering statements from coworkers and
friends that did not legally qualify as
victim impact statements were read
during the first sentencing hearing and
in today's sentencing the judge noted
that he did not think that the original
was unreasonable at all so he went ahead
and gave the same sentencing as the
first one again 15 to 44 years in prison
reporting outside the courthouse in
downtown hector mejia live local now